at Christmas lab at Dalhousie University
researchers developed the shopping cart
study to examine this question 15-month
Ainslie is introduced to the shopping
cart
after a brief demonstration researchers
wanted to see if Ainslie will figure out
how to get the cart to her mother
Aynsley pushes and pushes pushing over
the cart does not get any closer to a
mother push it push it
mommy see researchers believe that in
order for the baby human to solve this
problem they have to have a sense of
self at 15 months
Aynsley has no idea that it's her body
that is preventing the cart from moving
is that a special cart that's a very
special car next comes 14 month Oscar he
too can't figure out why the cart won't
move out of frustration he tries to
climb into the cart 16-month Maria gets
a bit closer to solving the mystery she
knows it has something to do with the
mat but doesn't make the further
connection to herself and thinks it's
the mats fault
shake him up you push it through he
eighteen-month jonathan pushes once and
steps off the mat he has quickly figured
out that he's the one who is the
obstacle to movie
which suggests that he is aware of
himself and his body abigail is also 18
months oh you're such a quick girl you
push it or watch your mom while she
takes a walk to the front of the cart to
analyze the problem it takes from no
time to understand that if she is
standing on the mat there is no way the
cart can move her solution is to roll up
the mat oh my goodness
from this researchers have concluded
that baby humans become aware of
themselves only after 18 months of life